Thousands of people gathered in the center of Buenos Aires to celebrate Maradona's life...
...and his love for Argentina's national team.
Diego Maradona was not just a football player for Argentina,...
...he was a national hero,...
...a man who came from some of the poorest areas in Buenos Aires and made it to the top,...
...to the best football clubs in the world.
Many of those who came here to say goodbye to him,...
...come from some of those areas, from poor areas,...
...and they say that Diego Maradona was one of them.
Sebastian is from a slum in the capital.
For me, he was like the love of my children.
I did not want to have this news.
I am destroyed.
I was too young to see him play,...
...but I know every goal by heart.
He gave us dignity so many times.
People here celebrate the goals against England in the 1986 World Cup,...
...three years after the war between both countries over the Malvinas Falklands Islands,....
...a goal that continues to be celebrated today.
Maradona will receive a hero's farewell.
He'll be lying in state in the presidential palace.
Around the world, Maradona is referred to as the best football player in the world.
For his fans, he was Diego,...
...a man, who in spite of his enormous struggles, filled Argentina with pride.